[Music]
so
3 a.m also using actual alarm clocks you
paid hundreds of dollars for that piece
of technology you carry around peralta
use it i thought you could get a head
start on heist prep staring at someone
while they sleep
and i made breakfast wait where are my
eggs well even if they had still been on
the plate the egg residue would have
been stuck to the underside of the sheet
once you made that maneuver and why
wouldn't you put the eggs on your
nightstand instead of in between the two
of you while you were sleeping
also we find out shortly captain holt is
the one who ate the eggs and now
i have so many questions how he even
knew they were under the comforter for
him to steal
also also i'm putting out an apb for an
nypd employee engaging in a bne with no
wng what if they've been mid piv
belt i'd like to see the pair of slacks
whose loops are large enough for this
belt no it is a cummerbund captain holt
would be well
a captain at tv sense any man or woman
resist can enter or woman in your
sentences if you mean human just say
human
or person or just anyone every man for
himself
it's like bachelor in paradise i'm
pretty sure that show's tagline is every
std for itself but
close enough because you're both losers
holt is about to insult every last
person in this room because of this
competition
and it feels like maybe that's a reason
to send the concept of competition
itself
now if everyone would rise rise like the
army of the dead
zack snyder references whoever has it at
midnight
will be declared shouldn't this
competition have a go moment
sure they hung the cummerbund but who
gets to say when the game begins
it's still in this room in fact
it's right here considering we find out
shortly jake is one of the main culprits
in this ruse i'm not sure why he's going
this far to avoid suspicion do you know
how hard it is to sew even one button
back on a shirt
everybody stop undressing we just had
harassment training
you mean harassment sensitivity training
because if you want to do actual
harassment training just have them binge
the police academy
you really thought movies could do this
without me gina i should have known it
was you
actually considering the mask voice
change and first person use of her own
name a detective like you should have
probably responded with who is this
really and the detectives around you
should have noticed you didn't and
immediately suspected you of shenanigans
oh look a boom mic dipping in the frame
and unlike your mockumentary brethren
you have no excuse to explain it away
whoever has it at midnight will be
declared the winner
of the fifth annual except before holt
didn't even get past the word declared
so this is some reenactment bs right
here
i'm highly doubtful imitation boyle
could have done all that in the few
seconds the lights were down but i'm
even more doubtful that they would have
risked it when a recorded message would
have done the trick just as well
also pretty impressive that you can
trigger a webcam to activate and
broadcast every monitor in the station
with a single push of a spacebar
after a station wide blackout you gotta
say bill your gina impression was spot
on but he used a voice modulator the
correct thing to say would be i gotta
say your impression of gina as
ghostface slash jigsaw was spot on
ghostsaw
jigface jigojin last year was a setup
hell yeah it was
i'm sick of you amy and hope winning but
gina won last year so is terry directing
his anger in the right place
tv sins doesn't think terry is okay
sarge lift up the super heavy thing that
no one else is strong enough to lift
there is no way terry is strong enough
to lift that especially with that high
center of gravity
also this server array that is
conveniently located in the center of
the server room has enough wasted space
underneath it to store a cumberbund
let's move don't cross the beam seems
like rosa could have triggered the beams
after they stepped out of the room
i've had enough heart attacks to know
what sweating looks like nuts sweat
that drop of sweat hit a few feet away
from holt are you telling me the
perspiration transportation made it this
far from the chair
did it yell i am a golden god before
making the leap was it on drugs
where is my dog better question where is
the one person responsible for training
imposter cheddar because this dog has
followed a stranger into a sensory
overloaded police station and is just
hanging out until someone relieves it of
its doppelganger duties and that
is impressive handmaid's tale this is
amy she won't shut up about how relevant
that show is in today's political
landscape
[Music]
handmaid's out they really listen to you
yeah i thought that was sinful too but
nowhere near as sinful as you getting
them all here that quickly and in that
office with enough costumes to pull this
off
it takes weeks just to get one
handmaid's costume delivered or
so i've heard i put a gps tracker on the
belt and you're just using it now
one of the handmaids i'm assuming fake
charles took my safe
and then of amy deposited a look-alike
add an exact replica safe to the
overflowing list of things miraculously
procured in mere minutes
well good luck figuring it out because
the clock is tick tick tocking
little-known fact tick-tick-tocking is
what i'm going to title my historical
account of how world war iii
started that one no the dust pattern on
top doesn't match its neighbors
if amy could figure this out so quickly
why did she wait for jake the flake to
get here instead of just absconding with
the belt for herself
amy santiago will you marry me
surprise i'm not even a huge fan of this
couple and that kind of melted my heart
what kind of witchcraft is this since
peralta altered the cummerbund no one
really won the heist this year okay fine
but there are a lot of unanswered
questions like at what point did jake
alter the belt
if no one else was in on it how could he
be certain she'd eventually be the one
to find it
if holton actually won would jacob
propose to him and live the rest of his
life in a polyamorous triad with raymond
and kevin
okay that last one may have just been
for me i planted the idea in jake's head
eight years ago it was eight years ago
so the show characters must have had
completely different hairstyles cliche
i don't get it seems pretty normal i
don't get it seems pretty normal title
of my sex tape
shall i list the ingredients now
cheddar if you've ever wanted to know
what it's like to probe into the back
end of cinemasins and learn our deepest
darkest secrets behind the sins podcast
is just what you need each week writers
aaron that's me today that's me
and jonathan yep discuss what it takes
to create the content that you enjoy on
youtube
hopefully enjoy they probably do i mean
even if they don't we talk about it
that's true i guess i'll just wrap this
up real quick and let you know that you
can listen to behind the scenes here on
youtube
or search for the show on your favorite
podcast player yep halloween
halloween in my belly get in my belly
hey over here losers hello amanda
you don't know me but i know you
i should have known it was you you punk
well do you punk
it is amazing how similar you guys look
a double pleasure's waiting for you
i don't see it me neither not a little
not at all and twins
even though i pretend not to be i've
realized that i am completely
codependent
but i'm cool with it because i think
that life should be shared now
and i need you to survive
okay that's your one sentence i i need
you to survive comma